play on very good teams for very good
organizations for great coaches and
great systems great players around us so
um just grateful for the opportunity to
compete grateful that we're in a
situation where we're battling you know
here in the division we've both been
around for quite a while so um
you know he's a great quarterback
um he's been so productive over a lot of
years and especially at the saints i i
was competing against him when he was at
purdue the two of us were playing each
other i played him
at michigan
um
you know he's just he's been a hell of a
player
combined age of 84 combined touchdown
passes of eleven hundred
and
tom brady and drew brees
cross paths for the second time this
year in the same division for the first
time saints traveling to visit the
buccaneers on sunday night football
my mind peter game of the week i'm not
doing the
you know perfunctory corporate
cheerleading here this is the game of
the week without question it's the game
of week last week eagles cowboys not the
game of the week this week saints
buccaneers absolutely positively the
most compelling game of the week
especially because of the fact that the
buccaneers have come so far from that
first game where they did go up seven to
nothing with a tom brady touchdown run
and then the saints ended up being the
better team that day
i just i can't wait to see what this
buccaneers offense does especially with
the arrival of antonio brown against the
saints team that will be overmatched on
defense but
appears to be getting michael thomas and
emmanuel sanders back to help drew brees
it just should i just hope for every
football fan out there it's a close high
scoring game that goes down to the wire
and i have a feeling it will be
you know one of the reasons it's so
interesting mike is that there's a good
chance this will be the last time that
tom brady and drew brees ever play
against each other
and
if that is the case if drew brees does
walk away at the end of this year if
that's the case
then i think we are looking at basically
two of not only two of the best
quarterbacks to ever play clearly but
statistically the best two quarterbacks
to ever play
and what's interesting about it is you
wonder how long
will that last statement last
in pro football history because of the
way everybody's throwing the ball now i
mean how many years is it going to take
for patrick mahomes to pass on both and
who knows maybe deshaun watson matt ryan
you you don't know but
the the the thing about this game that
to me is absolutely fascinating okay
sean payton gets all his weapons back
now he doesn't have to just deal with
austin carr you know now he's got
two his two premier receivers that he
basically
you know basically architected his
offense around in the offseason emmanuel
sanders obviously and michael thomas
so now they both come back
meanwhile you know mike if if i were if
i were bruce aliens
i'd walk into byron leftwitch's office
one of these days this week his
offensive coordinator and i'm going to
say look
you better get antonio brown ready
because
with uh you know with mike evans not
being 100
with scottie miller really struggling
with hip and groin injuries and whether
you have
chris godwin or not he's not healthy at
all and he's got the broken finger
you need a game-breaking player in this
game
and that's why to me i will not be
surprised i i right now if you had to go
to vegas mike let me ask you this
over under on snaps for antonio brown in
this game if i put it at 30
okay let's say they have 65 offensive
plays if i put it at 30 for antonio
brown what are you taking the over the
over over
me over i would too yup
yeah there's a reason why tom brady
there is a reason why tom brady
has taken antonio brown very quickly
under his wing stay in my house come
with me ride to work with me he is
inculcating him
right now
and and let not just in the offense
you know they have plenty of time for
that but he's also inculcating him and
he said dude
last chance coffee shop here this is it
you got to do it this is the golden
opportunity we can get you a super bowl
ring no one knows what the future holds
no one but right now live in the moment
and be great for us right now don't say
anything shut up
and go home every day
stay off social media
just play football for the next two and
a half three months and your life is
gonna be great
and sims and i talked about this earlier
in the week this isn't tom brady
deciding that
there's this charity case that he's
going to devote all this time to there's
a benefit to tom brady because antonio
of course
of course is potentially we're talked
earlier in the show about best receiver
in the game well one of the reasons
we're talking about all these other guys
is antonio brown hasn't played for the
last two years the last time the saints
saw antonio brown was his last game with
the steelers 14 catches 185 yards two
touchdowns that was the game where juju
smith schuster fumbles steelers get
knocked out of the playoffs because the
saints ended up winning 31-28 two days
later juju smith schuster is the team
mvp next day antonio brown has some sort
of a conniption
and storms out throws the ball at big
ben and never plays for the steelers
again so
that's the last football memory we have
of antonio brown in the steelers uniform
slicing and dicing the saints defense
and now
you've got mike evans you've got gronk
who is becoming gronk again you've got
tom brady at quarterback for crying out
loud you've got ronald jones and leonard
fournette who can do great things
underneath if the defense is going to be
obsessed with neutralizing the receivers
and yeah peter to get back to the point
tom brady is doing all this because he
knows
that if he can get antonio brown pointed
the right direction that means
super bowl number seven for tom brady
well mike you know what i when you were
talking about his last great moment
really his last great roman in the nfl
was the perfect corner route that brady
threw him with the patriots when he
caught it near the corner of the end
zone and he just jumped into the stands
in in miami which by the way what's so
interesting about that play that play
happened 1.2 miles from where antonio
brown was from you know and and so now
he gets a chance
again tom brady the prettiest throw he
has thrown this year
is the deep corner route to scotty
miller a couple of weeks ago and what
that told me
is that first of all everybody said uh
brady's deep arm it's flawed blah blah
blah blah no it isn't
he needs somebody to get two steps on a
corner
throw it to throw that corner out i
guarantee you that that is what you're
going to see with antonio brown this
week
antonio brown was with the patriots one
week
before that game he was a raider eight
days right before that game and look
peter
i have no proof to back this up but you
know what look around plenty of
accusations are being made this week
with absolutely no proof but i at least
have some circumstantial evidence to
back up what i'm about to say
i think that tom brady and antonio brown
have been working together
for a while and i think antonio brown
has had the buccaneers playbook for a
while and i wouldn't be surprised to
learn that antonio brown has been living
with tom brady for a while this isn't
something that just dropped out of the
blue a couple of weeks ago when the
seahawks were being not very discreet
about their interest in antonio brown
this has been in the works to the point
where
it would not surprise me to find out
that bruce arians deliberately said in
late march i don't want him
as a way to keep everyone else else off
the trail that they knew then
eventually they're gonna make a play for
this guy there's no reason to do it now
there's no reason to do it in august
there's no reason to do it until he is
approaching the end of his of whatever
punishment the league imposes on and
back in march we didn't know what it was
going to be let's sit tight we'll make
the move at the right time i believe all
of that other than the fact that that
bruce arians deliberately said we're not
interested i don't necessarily believe
that it just wouldn't surprise me
everything else i believe because
you know it was just a week and a half
ago they asked tom brady a very simple
question have you been working out with
or throwing to antonio brown and he
didn't answer and he answered a
different question that told me
everything i needed to know because it's
a simple question yes or no no i haven't
he's showing up here for the first time
and we got to get this thing going i
think that that rabbit hole of
connection between brady and brown goes
a lot deeper than we realize and i think
we're going to see the product of it on
sunday night
what what the way we would know the
answer to that question and really maybe
the only way we would know the answer to
that question mike
is if mike evans was
95
if
uh you know if chris godwin was 100 if
scotty miller was 98
you know and if oj howard was healthy
too now all of that is fairly
unrealistic
in the grind of an nfl season i get that
but
uh it's it's now been 11 days since i
asked bruce arians why antonio brown the
first word out of his mouth
injuries
and so
i believe right now that if all those
guys were healthy and it's as i say it's
unrealistic to think it's very rare that
you're gonna go through a season where
your four or five most important weapons
in the passing game by week nine of the
season are all healthy but if they were
i don't believe that they would have
signed antonio brown but you know i
still never know that
but let me let me give you my two cents
on that
i think that tom brady would not have
relented because he would have said you
never know when an injury is going to
happen or covet 19 situation is going to
happen let's have a guy at the bottom of
the roster that we can trust if need be
and also this never really got discussed
the way i think it should have been the
idea that there's a defensive element to
signing antonio brown because if the
buccaneers had said thank you no thank
you and he shows up on the packers who
according to adam schefter had made the
phone call to antonio brown if he shows
up on the seahawks
who were openly talking about it i think
openly talking about it to try to get
someone else to sign him frankly they
did their due diligence they weren't
comfortable but russell wilson wanted
him and if he's out there and russell
wilson keeps banging the drum at some
point john schneider may have to say
fine let's give him all a one strike
opportunity then if you're tom brady you
got to worry about this guy that you
want on your team
making it harder to get to the super
bowl because your defense is going to
have to deal with them when you face the
packers or the seahawks in the playoffs
i mean can you imagine antonio brown and
devonte adams
each lined up you know on opposite sides
of the field for aaron rodgers
i mean
it would have been unfair it really
would have been unfair i would have said
right then as much trouble as they've
had with stopping the run recently i
would have said the packers are going to
the super bowl
now
you know you also have to say to
yourself
if
something happens legally to antonio
brown in the next four or five weeks
and basically detours him from helping a
team deep into january if that happens
then all bets are off but mike you just
said something that i think is
absolutely a thousand percent true
because what the what the tampa bay
buccaneers did in keeping him away from
teams that definitely were interested
and there are others there are others in
the afc too that i think were kicking
the tires on this
it you know what what the what the bucks
did was not only good for their offense
but potentially come january could be
very good for their defense
and one last point on this before we
move on to the next game on the list
the idea that tom brady is being a great
teammate by giving antonio brown a place
to stay
let's not kid ourselves you mentioned
the possibility of antonio brown getting
in trouble at some point over the next
four or five weeks and ending
prematurely his run with the buccaneers
like he ended prematurely his run with
the raiders and then with the patriots
if he's living with tommy he ain't gonna
get in any trouble
that's part of it it's not just being
hospitable
it's babysitting
right it's making sure he doesn't get in
trouble if he's living with tom he ain't
getting in any trouble so another reason
to feel
very good about this if you're a
buccaneers fan and just fascinated if
you're a football fan about what happens
when these guys get back on the field
together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports